jeder dieser Erdhügel ist ein Grab
abseits der großen Städte mitten auf den
Feldern finden wir Belege dafür dass die
Zahl der corona-toten in China weit
höher sein muss als die Behörden sagen
sie ihre Toten hierher gebracht weil sie
in den Krematorien dort zu lange warten
muss
wir sind in der Provinz call Bay
unterwegs gut 100 km südlich von Peking
wir entdecken einige Erdhügel die mit
Gras überwachsen sind und viele bei
denen die Erde frisch aufgeschüttet
wurde alte und neue Gräber sind gut zu
unterscheiden
zahlreiche Erdhügel sind mit Blumen
geschmückt diese Landarbeiter bestätigen
uns dass es neue Gräber sind wir fragen
ob die Menschen an Corona gestorben sind
[Musik]
viel mehr Leute gestorben als sonst
wir suchen nach weiteren belegen neben
der Straße entdecken wir eine Art
Dekoration die halt verbrannt ist
diese Frau möchte unerkannt bleiben
erzählt uns aber dass es ein Baldachin
ist er sei erst vor kurzem für eine
Bestattung genutzt worden
wir fahren weiter und entdecken auf dem
Waldweg noch einen Baldachin
diese blumendecher werden traditionell
über Särgen getragen um den Toten die
letzte Ehre zu erweisen allein das ist
hier steht und noch sehr neu aussieht
zeigt hier ist jemand erst vor kurzem
gestorben
Glück und Wohlstand im Jenseits sagen
die Schriftzeichen auf dem blumendach
unter ihm ein frisches Grab
unmittelbar daneben weitere Ruhestätten
für die Toten die Erde ist noch frisch
wir fahren in den Nachbarort in
mybay-schwang sind sie auf Totenkult
spezialisiert auf der Hauptstraße reiht
sich ein Geschäft an das andere
hier kann man alles kaufen was den
Lieben im Jenseits Glück und Wohlstand
bringen soll
papierpuppenpapiergeld einen Plastik
E-Bike ein Pferd
doch unsere Ankunft ist nicht willkommen
geht weg sagt diese Frau Filmen sei hier
verboten dann werden wir aus dem Laden
gebeten
wir wissen nicht ob sich bereits herum
besprochen hat dass ich ein Kamerateam
zu den Kurve Toten erkundigt oder ob die
Frau einfach nicht gestört werden will
ein paar Meter weiter haben wir mehr
Glück wir treffen auf Herrn der
einwilligt und sein Lager zu zeigen er
ist auf Papier gelanden Toten Decken und
Kleidung für Verstorbene spezialisiert
er erzählt uns dass das Geschäft noch
nie so gut lief wie in den vergangenen
Wochen
schauen Sie sich unsere Regale an hier
ist fast nichts mehr da in unseren zwei
Lagern gibt es keine totenanzüge mehr
wir haben nicht gedacht dass sich das
Virus so schnell verbreitet
viele die gestorben sind sind 90 Jahre
und älter
mit der kobit-welle kam der Ansturm auf
seinen Laden
ich habe das noch nie erlebt so viel
haben wir wirklich seit Generationen
nicht verkauft
quetschen bestätigt uns das tote aus
Peking zur Einäscherung in den kleinen
Ort gebracht wurden
nachdem sie die Toten ihr eine Woche
lang verbrannt hatten wollten sie die
Leute aus Peking nicht mehr einäschern
weil es einfach zu viele waren
ein paar Meter weiter schließt Frau pay
gerade ihr Geschäft auf sie verkauft
Grabgestecke Kunstblumen in allen
möglichen Farben
wir verkaufen gerade drei bis fünf Mal
so viel und in ganz China
Leid und Geschäft liegen in diesem Dorf
ganz nah beieinander wie viele Menschen
in China an COBIT gestorben sind darüber
gibt es kaum verlässliche Zahlen doch es
gibt Berichte von Augenzeugen und es
gibt die vielen Gräber die wir gesehen
haben sie sprechen eine andere Sprache
als die offizielle chinesische
corona-statistik die knapp 80.000
Todesfälle verzeichnet
internationale Experten gehen von weit
über einer Million Kobe Toten aus
wir sind bislang von zwei coved-wellen
in China ausgegangen jetzt aber nur noch
von einer großen
schneller als erwartet in die ländlichen
Gebiete ausgebreitet der Höhepunkt ist
aber erreicht die Zahlen gehen langsam
herunter
das Forschungsinstitut arbeitet mit
Daten aus aller Welt mit den wenigen
vorhandenen aus China aber auch mit
Daten aus Ländern die eine ähnliche
Politik gefahren sind wie die
Volksrepublik Neuseeland z.B oder
Hongkongs
angeschaut wie viele Tote es bei wie
vielen infizierten gab würden die
offiziellen chinesischen Zahlen stimmen
wäre die Zahl der Toten in China 250 Mal
geringer als die in Hongkong und 20 mal
geringer als in Neuseeland da hatten wir
angefangen die chinesischen Zahlen zu
hinterfragen
und Neuseeland waren viel mehr Menschen
durch eine Impfung geschützt
zurück auf dem chinesischen Land
Chinas Kobe Tote sind nicht zu übersehen
die Regierung will dass das Volk davon
nichts mitbekommt aber dass die
offiziellen Zahlen nicht stimmen können
liegt auch daran dass gar nicht alle
Toten registriert werden die Toten die
hier liegen tauchen nicht in der
offiziellen Statistik auf denn sie zählt
nur Menschen die in der Klinik an Kurve
gestorben sind aber hier auf dem Land
dauert es oft mehrere Kilometer bis zum
nächsten Krankenhaus aufsteht oft kein
Arzt zur Verfügung um den Tod
festzustellen wenn jemand in seinem Haus
gestorben ist also wie viele Kurve tote
China am Ende zählen wird wird wohl
niemand erfahren